okay you ready Nicholson baby your hand
alone yeah you might want to start with
you for real quick all right let's bring
up the next bro Oh
shield Oh Brooke Shields
[Applause]
all right good good all right Aquaman
next one oh gosh thank goodness because
you got your son Daniel Levy Martin
Scorsese I can smell that part
[Applause]
yeah that fridge okay let's see Oh exact
shirt oh my god I knew this I know this
I better know that no I know I know this
I know this he can still I know this I'm
blanking you're gonna really hate
yourself am i yeah go ahead
and my arrow straight I thought it was
like an actor it's like from the like
long ago like 40s
that's like retro boy yeah because her
eyebrows so she she's retro yeah it was
somebody from like sorry right you right
now all your music that counts right I
think it's it still tasted good okay
yeah sorry lady in the next picture okay
oh god you got it mi see
[Applause]
we can give them a point for singing
we're time dude I'm a Mario Brothers
freak let's see the next next Brown
Groucho song alone got you the wind I
know this hurts as competitive as my son
then subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going